first Minister for over eight years and
I was Deputy first minute for the
minister for the best part of eight
years before that
these jobs are a privilege but they are
also rightly hard and especially in the
case of first Minister relentlessly so
now to be clear I'm not expecting
violins here but I am a human being as
well as a politician
when I entered government in 2007
my niece and youngest nephew were babies
just months old as I stepped down they
are about to celebrate their 17th
birthdays
now I think about it that's exactly the
age to be horrified at the thought of
your auntie suddenly having more time
for you
my point is this giving absolutely
everything of yourself to this job is
the only way to do it the country
deserves nothing less
but in truth that can only be done by
anyone for so long for me it is now in
danger of becoming too long
the first minister is Never Off Duty
particularly in this day and age there
is virtually no privacy
even ordinary stuff that most people
take for granted like going for a coffee
with friends or for a walk on your own
becomes very difficult
and the nature and form of modern
political discourse means that there is
a much greater intensity did I see it
brutality to Life as a politician than
in Years Gone by
all in all
and actually for a long time without it
being apparent it takes its toll on you
and on those around you
and if that is true in the best of times
it has been more so in recent years